we begin with this in Dallas the white
former Dallas police officer convicted
of murdering her black neighbor in his
own home could spend the rest of her
life in prison the jury deliberated for
less than seven hours before finding
amber Geiger guilty of murder yesterday
for shooting and killing both of John
last year the case is now in the
sentencing phase and jurors are hearing
more evidence including racially
insensitive text messages Geiger shared
Omar Villafranca is at the courthouse in
Dallas
Omar how will those text messages factor
in sentencing do we think
well prosecutors are showing the jurors
or text messages the social media posts
to kind of give them a sense of who
Geiger is and that evidence will factor
into their sentencing and after
yesterday's hearing there's a lot for
them to go over and keep in mind she
faces five to 99 years in prison my life
has not been the same it's just been
like a roller coaster
both of John's mother Alison testified
at a sentencing hearing Tuesday about
how her life has changed since amber
Geiger shot and killed her son it's just
been the most terrible time for me the
jury convicted the former police officer
of murder after deliberating for less
than seven hours we the jury unanimously
find the defendant Amber Geiger guilty
of murder as charged in the indictment
cheers erupted in the courtroom as the
verdict was announced John's family
embraced Geiger set crying at the
defense table
j'onn family attorneys saying this
outcome is justice for other unarmed
black victims in this verdict is for
Trayvon Martin it's for Michael Brown
it's for Sandra bland it's but Tamir
rice is for Eric Gardner today the jury
will review new evidence for sentencing
prosecutors already presented racially
insensitive text she sent last year
while working at a Martin Luther King
Day Parade
when does this end lol outgoing message
from the defendant when MLK is dead dot
dot dot oh wait
prosecutors also showed the jury some of
Geiger's social media posts that
promoted police violence against
civilians attorneys say this new
evidence shows Giger's true intent we
believe that it takes a completely
different picture than that the crying
tearful remorseful person was on a stage
according to studies since the beginning
of 2005 out of 100 hundred and six
officers arrested for shootings while on
duty thirty five had been convicted of a
crime now keep in mind this case is a
little bit different since Geiger was
off-duty jury will be back here at 9:30
and there's not really a good idea of
how long the sentencing phase will last
Tony
Omar thank you very much